ein aktueller kinofilm bringt es jetzt
auf den punkt power to change rückt
einige argumente gerade und zeigt wie
einfach die energiewende auch sein kann
aber warum kommt die energiewende
weltweit nur relativ langsam ins rollen
der film zeigt den einfluss der
wirtschaft auf die politik was
unternehmen lobbyisten um ihre
wirtschaftlichen interessen vor die
energiewende zu stellen
beginnen wir erst mal mit denen die den
wandel zuerst und im großen stil
vorantreiben müssen politikerinnen und
politiker die politik die es deshalb
ausschlaggebend
weil sie gesetze erlassen kann politik
beschließt auch subventionen ja
erneuerbare energien werden zb in
deutschland unterstützt allerdings
werden auch herkömmliche arten energie
zu erzeugen gefördert und das kann
unterschiedliche gründe haben
der kohleabbau zum beispiel hat vor
allem im ruhrgebiet ist er teil der
arbeiterkultur viele menschen hatten und
haben noch jobs im bereich der
kohleindustrie klar wenn man diese
arbeitsplätze einfach schlecht ohne eine
alternative für die arbeiter geschaffen
zu haben dann ist das eine sehr
unpopuläre entscheidung 2015 sei der
konzern rwe in nordrhein westfalen fast
100.000 arbeitsplätze bedroht da
wirtschaftsminister sigmar gabriel
plante co2 ausstoßen betriebe abgaben
zahlen zu lassen also eben
kohlekraftwerke nun damit so etwas nicht
passiert schicken die konzerne dieser
welt gerne lobbyisten los die ihre
interessen in den kreisen der politik
vertreten die einfluss auf die politik
ist dermaßen hoch dass lobbyismus auch
schon mal als die fünfte macht im land
bezeichnet wird auch die kernkraft
industrie hat ihre lobbyisten die
fleißig für die interessen der
kraftwerksbetreiber agieren natürlich
gibt es auch lobbyismus von
umweltverbänden ein gleichgewicht
zwischen den verschiedenen lagern
existiert aber nicht im film power to
change geht es auch über die
einflussnahme im internationalen bereich
als beispiel die ukraine
da sind die filmemacher in die ukraine
gereist um zu erfahren was politik und
internationale einflussnahme ausrichten
in deutschland werden inzwischen rund 30
prozent des stroms durch erneuerbare
energien gewonnen
von paar jahrzehnten hat sich das noch
niemand vorstellen können
das klingt erstmal nach fortschritt
allerdings ist die lage so den
energieanbietern wurden co2 zertifikate
erteilt sie dürfen eu-weit eine
bestimmte menge co2 ausstoßen wenn jetzt
in deutschland mehr windräder stehen
können den anderen europäischen staaten
dennoch kohlekraftwerke gebaut werden
eingespart wird co2 also nicht
automatisch neue energien kosten viel
geld man muss windräder errichten dächer
mit solarzellen ausstatten dagegen ist
der etablierte atomstrom doch eine
günstige alternative könnte man auf den
ersten blick glauben aber die mehrkosten
sind eigentlich allen bekannt genau
heute an dem
dann nehmen wir dieses video aufzeichnen
jetzt sich die reaktorkatastrophe von
tschernobyl zum dreißigsten mal vor fünf
jahren kam es zur katastrophe von
fukushima und das sind die bekanntesten
aber nicht die einzigen vorfälle bei
denen sich zeigt wie verheerend
kernenergie sein kann es gibt eine sehr
sehr lange liste mit zum teil
verheerenden atomunfällen und selbst
wenn alles nach plan läuft
atomkraftwerke produzieren atommüll in
form von ausgedienten brennstäben
mischoxiden verstrahlten werkzeugen aus
den werken und sogar benutzte kleidung
der mitarbeiter 12.000 tonnen dieser
abfallprodukte entstehen jedes jahr
weltweit für den müll gibt es immer noch
seit jahrzehnten kein endlager in
deutschland experten schätzen dass die
suche nach einer geeigneten städte bis
sogar in die mitte des nächsten
jahrhunderts dauern könnte
ja man schätzt dass im jahr 2170 ein
geeignetes lager befüllt und geschlossen
werden könnte
die kosten für die suche sollen auch
noch ansteigen auf 50 bis 70 milliarden
euro
ja dazu kommen noch dimension die sich
ein einzelner mensch kaum vorstellen
kann das endlager soll sicherheit für
eine million jahre bieten aber selbst
wenn man sich die halbwertszeit der zu
lagernden stoffe ansieht die ja
wesentlich kürzer sind erkennt man wie
lange die menschheit mit der dazu im
verhältnis kurzen periode des atomstroms
zu tun hat plutonium 239 zum beispiel
hat eine halbwertszeit von 24.000 jahren
also plutonium benötigt 24.000 jahre
damit es noch halb soviel strahlt und
setzt dann ist plutonium noch extrem
giftig es braucht also x-mal 24.000
jahre bis plutonium wirklich
ungefährlich ist in deutschland werden
viele atomkraftwerke beschlossen aber
selbst solche gebäude abzureißen dauert
seine zeit und viele teile der gebäude
sind auch atommüll und so ganz kommt die
atomkraft ja ohne den ausstoß von co2
auch nicht aus durch den abbau des
benötigten urans kommt es ebenfalls zur
produktion von co2 bei der aufbereitung
des uranerz kann es vorkommen dass die
energie hineingesteckt werden muss viel
höher ist als die energie die am ende
durch das atomkraftwerk produziert wird
in den abbaustätten stellt das relativ
schwach strahlende uran zwar keine allzu
große gefahr da allerdings können durch
den abbau schwermetall verbindung das
trinkwasser verunreinigen uran zerfällt
zudem zu radon einem edelgas das zu
lungenkrebs führen kann und in den
abbaugebieten oder halten kann sich das
gas an
was ist los farblos geschmacklos und
kann deshalb unbemerkt eingeatmet werden
im film geht es allerdings nicht nur um
großkonzerne und politik was kann jeder
einzelne selbst tun um mit kostbaren
energie nicht zu verschwenderisch
umzugehen beispiel auto statussymbol
individuelle mobilität aber muss es
immer das eigene auto sein das die
meiste zeit des tages ungenutzt
herumsteht carsharing wäre eine
alternative und das ist schon seit
einiger zeit ein beliebter trend im
januar 2016 wurden in deutschland 1 2
millionen registrierte nutzer bei
carsharing unternehmen verzeichnet aber
einfach weiter mit verbrennungsmotoren
mobil sein
der welthandel mit erdöl hat negative
folgen sogar für uns jeder kann ein
wenig dafür tun dass wir einen wandel
nicht nur in unserem denken vollziehen
sondern auch in unserem handeln
ich selbst habe den letzten jahren auch
einiges geändert der strom kommt bei mir
von einem ökostromanbieter ich fahre rad
zug straßen oder s-bahn und fliege viel
seltener und habe kein auto mehr ich
esse weniger fleisch kaufe regionale
produkte damit nicht so viel
transportiert werden muss und das
möglichst im biomarkt zusammenfassung
macht mit schaut den film an ändert was
tut was was ihr für richtig haltet
darüber dass sich etwas ändern muss da
sind sich eigentlich alle einig und wenn
jeder ein bisschen anders macht ist das
schon eine menge
ich will den disclaimer geben
journalisten sollten sich nie mit einer
sache gemein machen das tue ich hier
auch nicht objektiv bedeuten fossile
energie und atomkraft das ende der
menschheit regenerative energie ist
billiger besser und schädigt unsere
umwelt viel weniger zudem gibt es keinen
anderen weg da nur sie mit abstand viel
ungefährlicher ist als andere energie
wer für kohle- oder atomkraftwerke ist
und gegen windkraft und gegen
sonnenenergie und so weiter der sollte
sich nochmal schwer überlegen was die
folgen sind wie krieg krebs
umweltverschmutzung klimawandel und so
weiter ich habe ich jetzt 30 jahre mit
dem thema beschäftigt und muss ja mal
ziemlich deutlich position beziehen
bei diesem video freue ich mich deshalb
ganz besonders über einen daumen hoch
von euch und darüber dass er fleißig
teilt in allen sozialen medien medien
schreibt mir bitte in die kommentare ob
es okay fahne dass ich hier so klar
position bezogen habe und sagt natürlich
auch eure meinung zum thema vergesst
nicht
den kanal zu abonnieren ist kostenlos
und ansonsten bis zum nächsten mal bis
dann bleibt dran